I want to talk about your beginnings
because obviously you have us this great
career very impressive career but I
always like to try and bring people back
to when they're near first starting out
and I didn't realize this you got
started out in a horror movie yeah in
1996 yeah a movie called
Hellraiser bloodline yeah right yeah we
have we have a picture of you a still of
you from Hellraiser bloodline there you
are with that the four the four I just
want to tell everybody that photo don't
worry it's not real that was it's fine
so I'm curious was that I mean you must
have been yours because you're still a
young guy that you got been extra to get
a movie at that age you are young at the
time
oh it was such a big deal it was the
first like real movie I got a role in
and I mean I really did think like oh
well this is it right I mean it's all
downhill from you like I am now it's
gonna be everything that happened before
Hellraiser bloodline and then everything
after like right I may as well just go
talk to my friends and just say listen
guys it's not a big deal I'm still the
same guy yeah okay I still put my pants
on one foot at a time and don't worry
about it it's just it's Adam it's me
I really felt like this was going to be
it and so the day came where I started
the movie a got up extra early I went
drove to like a real movie set with like
trailers and cameras and the trucks
everywhere I go to hair and makeup they
put a wig on me and this outlandish
costume I have a dress a trailer it's
like a small one where the toilet is
like next to the chair where you eat
your food
but still and they knock on the door and
they're ready for you and like I went to
they walk me to the set they're like oh
we're gonna bring you to your chair and
I was like oh my god I get a chair a
chair like a Hollywood movie with yeah
I'm on that iconic chair yes and they
bring me over and and they they're like
okay here you go and the chair there is
chair and it says Adam Craig on the joke
which isn't my name no yeah so what was
the deal I don't know I didn't mention
it because I was too scared they just
had your name so there wasn't another
person on the set name Adam Craig no did
someone just didn't care and wrote him
because it was Hellraiser bloodline and
who cares
I just wasn't aware of that well it got
you launched you know yeah it sure did
so we all know you yeah it's one of the
only movies directed by Alan Smithee
which is the name that the Directors
Guild uses if no one wants to take
credit for the movie oh is that true
yeah it's like one of three movies
directed by Alan's my fake wait that's
the name they use on movies if no one
wants to take credit for it right we
should start calling this show smite be
it's might be and then I come out and
I'm like it wasn't here
[Applause]